le temps fort incontestablement de cette
année c'est cette petite peluche qui
s'appelle Elmo chatouill moi pour un peu
plus âgé vous avez la console Nintendo
64 bit deux fois plus performante que la
précédente et qui est en train
évidemment de rafler le marché de la
vidéo cette année le monde du
fantastique a aussi ses jeunes adeptes
dans ce magasin les ventes augmentent de
30 % pour Noël jeu de rôle figurine de
la Guerre des étoiles et surtout les
bande dessiné les mangas alors bon ça
apparu bon j'étais j'ai trouvé un manga
par hasard comme ça puis depuis je fais
quel collection de ça je peux plus
m'arrêter et pour tous les connaisseurs
de Spawn la bande dessinée vendue aux
États-Unis le héros arrive en force au
cinéma le 12 décembre mais aussi dans la
hautete du Père Noël un autre univers
futuriste d'origine anglaise connaît un
grand succès auprès des jeunes Games
Workshop des jeux guerriers avec une
règle et plusieurs d Guillaume avait
déjà repérer le magasin j'aime bien les
guerriers et puis euh le futur et le
passé ça me plaît